she has a cat named inertia
and this cat because i spent so much
time walking across her keyboard
has inspired a warby academy class
called data cleaning with cats
do you have please welcome stacy
hello
i'm here to tell you
that you already have the perfect data
science stakeholder
now some of you are sitting there and
saying wait but my stakeholders aren't
really data-driven that's okay
you can fix them up a bit with a
data-driven makeover
using lessons learned from tv makeovers
that transform people's look home and
habits
ready
go
wait how do i advance
this one
sorry
can someone show me how to advance the
slides
it's not going
not on there
space enter
no
no help
[Laughter]
help someone
can see it on my computer um hello
[Laughter]
help
this is
totally i don't i don't know where it
went
and i don't know how to advance it
use these
no it didn't work
oh now it works okay perfect you're good
yes
okay so a regular makeover starts
perhaps this person i care about could
focus on themselves and do a little bit
better let me call the makeover team so
how does a warby parker makeover start
well neil and dave our co-ceos sometimes
call people into a room and say this is
good but maybe you could be more data
driven
and this doesn't mean they're not using
data already or they aren't using it
well
but they do want a little bit less i
feel it in my heart
and a little bit more i feel it in my
dashboard
so how does the data science team play
into this because we are not dashboard
makers and we don't want to be
well we do three things on our data
science team
one is ai or ml models like the
technology that enables you to virtually
try on glasses
we do decision support
for very complex questions with huge
business impact
like we did the analysis around where to
put the second optical lab it was in las
vegas and if you're interested in those
two types of things i have other
colleagues at this conference and you
should find them i think christina is
here today but the thing that i do at
warby parker is i do data literacy
and what that means is empowering people
with the skills and tools necessary to
understand explore use and make
decisions with data and communicate
those decisions effectively
now why are we investing time and energy
here
we're not asking everyone to become a
data scientist or develop some magic ai
machine but every single stakeholder can
learn how to be more data savvy and
understand how to use their data more
effectively and efficiently
my job is to create opportunities for
them to move up that spectrum so we can
distribute the squishy middle of complex
problems across more people in the
company
when this happens analysts are empowered
they feel ownership over their problems
and it increases the bandwidth of all
analysis at warby parker the company can
know things about itself really really
quickly and make good decisions
so what do i do to achieve moving up
that spectrum well most of my time i
spend creating and delivering broadly
applicable training resources and tools
for the whole organization like data
cleaning with cats and some smaller
amount of my time i spend doing these
data-driven makeovers
for
specific teams that are stuck on a very
high value problem
so now that we've established the need
for the makeover and that i am the
person doing this there are two ways
that this makeover can go
the first way is i cannot believe you've
been living in squalor and ignorance
this whole time you should feel very bad
about yourself and that is definitely
not my preferred method
the way i go about
approaching this makeover is you are a
very successful person with a lot of
completing competing priorities
and perhaps
if we can focus in on your data for a
bit
you can dramatically improve your
workflows i want to be their data
science fairy godmother
so before we can go into the actual
things that can transform these
workflows we have to acknowledge the
elephant in the room and that is that
on makeover shows personal grooming
definitely makes some people nervous but
what i've discovered giving these
data-driven makeovers is data really
makes some people nervous
and this is indicated by things people
say to me in the first meeting first is
like i was in english or a french or a
music major how many people in this room
were a liberal arts major just so i can
like take this back
thank you thank you my liberal arts
people i was not but
but
people confide in me that they failed
eighth grade algebra i like like that
doesn't have any impact on your work
issue
or they'll quietly say that you know by
the way i'm not a math person
so
the first thing i do is i quote
makeover icon jonathan van ness
and say when people say you can't teach
an old dog new tricks that's not true
because you can reinvent yourself and
learn new things whenever you want
and then i can also position
my stakeholder as a hero or heroine
actually recognizing them as the domain
experts that they are
and this is freeing because
as the person that's helping them i
don't need to know everything in the
world just a few tips and tricks to up
their game because i can ask basic
questions about their data and learn
about whole new functional areas of the
business that i've never considered
before
and also when you recognize your
stakeholder as a hero or heroine you're
helping them build their confidence to
embrace new skills
and you can say something like
wow look at that gorgeous data you're
generating
i should qualify this by saying make
sure it's true because if it's not your
stakeholder is gonna see right through
that immediately
now i'm gonna present some actual tips
and tricks i've used which is a little
scary in this audience because they're
geared very much for data beginners
so imagine yourself way back at the
beginning of your data journey or
alternatively if you were data driven in
utero put on your empathy hat
and empathize with someone with a
dramatically different skill set that
are domain experts in their field
but these suggestions are going to be
pretty basic
so
something i learned from makeover shows
when you see someone who has a mullet
you know that that mullet is gonna have
to go
maybe even first
the subject of the makeover doesn't know
this
i don't know how i feel like i would
research that before getting on
television
often that mullet has served that person
for a very long time
and trusting someone to cut that off
is a really big deal so what's the data
science equivalent of a mullet
well
storing categorical variables is
free-form text
this is a housing listing
and it says welcome to your perfectly
located three-bedroom one-bathroom row
home complete with fantastic full living
room dining room kitchen ground level
recreation room and separate entry
direct access from your fully fenced in
backyard one car attached garage with
space for two cars located one block
from nyc transportation and moments from
shopping restaurants and entertainment
this gem is not to be missed
and because you're all data scientists
you know you can pull valuable
categorical information out of this free
text including
bedrooms bathrooms friends fenced in
yards basements and garages and that
will allow you to compare it to other
properties
my stakeholders don't always know this
so i inform them and sometimes it's a
real mind shift that takes a bit to get
used to
what's another makeover tip that i can
give my stakeholders
some makeovers are focused on healthy
habits
and that type of makeover could teach
you to make eggs
this isn't a deeply impressive culinary
skill but if you didn't know how to do
it before it's going to dramatically
improve your life
what's a data mullet
data eggs i'm sorry um is there a
pattern to how your data is wrong
because if there is you could clean it
with a formula and not touch individual
entries ever again
and then
when you get to a home makeover
and you see a sink full of dishes
you know that makeover team is not going
to stand there on national television
washing things
but they might embrace permanent
automation by installing a dishwasher in
that home
and i definitely encourage my
stakeholders to embrace permanent
automation
so i'm never going to make a dashboard
for you but if i teach you how to use
our bi tool you are never gonna update a
dashboard ever again at 9am on monday
so when picking areas of focus i like to
think about pain
and impact
the ideal project to start with is low
pain
and high impact
what does low pain look like a really
quick automation a time saver something
they talk about wow i'm so excited to
try this
high impact could be dollars time
savings understanding a problem they're
thinking about
a higher pain solution number two up
there um
requires more trust leaving aside
conventional wisdom
abandoning a tool they're really
comfortable with it takes a lot of time
to implement or leaving the defaults in
anything
and min makeover you know it's working
when people start saying i'm really
curious about something else or how am i
going to learn more about this or
i want to make sure i can do this on my
own can you show me how to do all those
things again
and we want to set them up for success
during and after this makeover so like a
makeover show we want to make sure we
leave them with souvenirs
instead of clothing or home renovation
or lots of
toiletries we leave our stakeholders
with learning resources like
documentation books e-learning warby
academy courses analyst guild office
hours we leave them with higher quality
analysis once we've partnered on a
specific project
we want to make sure the analysis that
comes out of that makeover is really
good something our stakeholder can be
proud to put on their boss's desk or
even hand off to neil and dave
and we want to make sure all of this
fits into the rubric of demonstrated
skills for their performance review or
promotion packet
so they're going to come out as a winner
at this point we've gotten our
stakeholder to their confident place
with their data
we've armed them with a few tips and
tricks
and they have a path forward to learn
more
and we know this is really working
at the end of a project when people say
wow my work is so much faster and more
reliable or
i feel more set up for success than i
ever have before
or in one particularly meaningful case
our design team who worked on crafting
beautiful things every day announced at
their all hands meaning that after
working with us their data was a thing
of beauty and i actually wept
so
at this point you realize i care very
deeply
about this
but data literacy work is core to the
data science mission
why is that
well we have 150 people at warby parker
who can now create dashboards
we have a thousand people that read
those dashboards
those generate 1.5 million queries every
week
and our data scientists don't touch any
of that
thank you
[Applause]